find the difference express the answer
as a simplified rational expression and
state the domain so we have two rational
expressions and we're subtracting one
from the other and just like when we
first learn to subtract fractions or add
fractions we have to find a common
denominator and the best way to find a
common denominator for just dealing with
regular numbers or with algebraic
expressions is to factor them out and
make sure that our common denominator
has all of the factors in it that'll
ensure that's divisible by the two
denominators here so this guy right here
is completely factored he's just a plus
two this one over here let's see if we
can factor it a squared plus 4a plus
four well you see the pattern the four
is 2 squared 4 is 2 times 2 so a squared
plus 4a plus 4 is a plus 2 times a plus
2 or a plus 2 squared so we say it's a
plus 2 times a plus 2 that's what a
squared plus 4a plus 4 is so this is
obviously divisible by itself
everything is divisible by itself except
I guess 4 0 is divisible by itself and
it's also divisible by a plus 2 so this
is the least common multiple of this
expression and that expression and it
could be a good common denominator so
let's set that up so let's set them this
will be the same thing as being equal to
this first term right here a minus 2
over a plus 2 a minus 2 over a plus 2
but we want the denominator now to be a
plus 2 times a plus 2 we want it to be a
plus 2 squared so let's multiply this
numerator and denominator by a plus 2 so
it's denominator is the same thing as
this so let's multiply both the
numerator and the denominator by a plus
2 by a plus 2 and we're going to assume
that a is not equal to negative 2 that
would have made this undefined it would
have also made this undefined so
throughout this whole thing we're going
to assume that a cannot be equal to
negative 2 the domain is all real
numbers a can be any real number except
for negative 2 so the first term is that
extend the line a little bit and then
the second term doesn't change because
this denominator is already the common
denominator so minus a minus 3 over and
we could write it either as a plus 2
times a plus 2
or as this thing over here let's write
in the factored form it'll make it
easier to simplify later on a plus 2
times a plus 2 and now before we let's
set this up like this now before we add
the numerators it'll probably make be a
good idea to multiply this out right
there but let me write the denominator
we know what that is it is a plus 2
times a plus 2 now this numerator if we
have a minus 2 times a plus 2 we've seen
that pattern before we can multiply it
out if you like but we've seen it enough
hopefully to recognize that this is
going to be a squared minus 2 squared or
this is going to be a squared minus 4
you can multiply it out the middle terms
cancel out the negative 2 times a
cancels out with the a times 2 and
you're just left with a squared minus 4
that's that over there and then you have
this you have - you have minus a minus 3
so let's be very careful here you're
subtracting a minus 3 so you want to
distribute the negative sign or multiply
both of these terms times negative 1 so
you could put a minus a here and then
negative negative 3 is plus 3 so what
does this simplify to you have a squared
a squared minus a minus a plus let's see
negative 4 plus 3 is negative 1 all of
that over all of that over a plus 2
times a plus 2 or we could just rewrite
we could write that as a plus 2 squared
a plus 2 squared now we might want to
factor this numerator out more to just
make sure it doesn't contain a common
factor with the denominator the
denominator is just 2 a plus 2 is
multiplied by themselves and you can see
from inspection a plus 2 will not be a
factor in this top expression I mean if
it was this number right here would be
divisible by 2 it's not divisible by 2
so a plus 2 is not one of the factors
here so there's not going to be any more
simplification even if we wanted you
know even if we even if we were able to
factor this thing in the numerator out
so we're done we have simplified the
rational expression and the domain is
all for all A's except for a cannot or
all A's given that a does not equal
negative to all A's except for negative
two and we are done